This course is about exactly these challenging problems.
Problems that are really, really tough for computers to solve.
But it is also a course about what to do with those challenging problems.
So how you can solve them using a computer despite them being very hard to solve.
Now, the part of computer science that deals with challenging problems
is called theoretical computer science.
The first part of theoretical computer science that we will be looking at is called complexity theory.
And complexity theory is the science of how much, or more specifically, how much resources.
So time, or memory, and also other resources a computer will need to solve a given problem.
The other part of theoretical computer science that we'll be looking at is called computability.
And computability asks the more fundamental question.
Computability asks, can a computer solve a given problem at all,
given as much time and as much memory as you want?
Now, this course will be mostly looking at complexity theory,
but we'll also do computability for 2 reasons:
First of all, it kind of belongs in the whole picture,
to say what computers can do and cannot do.
And the other reason is that many problems that fall into the area of computability
are actually very relevant, and it's important to understand computability
to know what is doable and what isn't.
And it's also important to understand computability to know what's possible in general and what isn't.